>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING AND
WELCOME TO TUCKER CARLSON
SENT TONIGHT.
A COUPLE HOURS AGO "THE
WASHINGTON POST" HOMETOWN
NEWSPAPER PUBLISHED OP-ED BY
FORMER FBI DIRECTOR JAMES
COMEY.
IN THE PIECE HE SAID
WHATEVER SURVEILLANCE THE
FBI DEPARTMENT CONDUCTED ON
THE 2016 TRUMP CAMPAIGN WAS
ENTIRELY JUSTIFIED AND
WITHIN BOUNDS.
NOTHING WEIRD ABOUT IT THE
AT ALL.
YES AMERICAN CITIZENS WERE
MONITORED ELECTRONICALLY
WITHOUT THEIR KNOWLEDGE.
BUT IT WASN'T SPYING.
OF COURSE IT WASN'T SPYING.
IT WAS INVESTIGATING.
IT WAS DONE FOR YOUR OWN
GOOD.
AND IF YOU DON'T LIKE IT,
YOU ARE UNPATRIOTIC AND
POSSIBLY MENTALLY ILL.
THAT'S COMEY'S POSITION.
WHAT THE OP-ED DID NOT
CONTAIN WAS ANY EVIDENCE AT
ALL THAT WHAT HE DID IS
TRUE.
COMEY IS A BITTER PARTISAN
WITH A LONG HISTORY OF
SHADING THE TRUTH.
BUT HE SUGGESTS YOU HAVE GOT
TO TRUST HIM ANYWAY.
IT'S YOUR DUTY TO TRUST HIM
OKAY.
WELL, HERE IS ANOTHER IDEA.
WE COULD SEE FOR OURSELVES
EXACTLY WHAT HAPPENED IN
2016 WE COULD DECLASSIFY ALL
THE RELEVANT INFORMATION AND
THEN MAKE IT PUBLIC THAT WAY
WE WOULDN'T HAVE TO TAKE
ANYONE'S WORD FOR WHAT
HAPPENED COMEY'S WORD,
TRUMP'S WORD, ANYONE ELSE'S
WORKED.
THE PRESIDENT SUGGESTED
DOING JUST THAT THE LEFT IS
OUTRAGED BY THE IDEA.
WATCH.
>> TRUMP HAS EVERY REASON TO
BELIEVE BARR WILL USE HIS
NEW POWERS TO AID THE
PRESIDENT'S ANTI-DEEP STATE
PROPAGANDA EFFORTS.
>> TRUMP GIVING BARR
UNILATERAL AUTHORITY OVER
CLASSIFICATION IS A HUGE
DEAL THE IN WORLD OF
INTELLIGENCE AGENCIES.
BARR WILL BE ABLE TO
OVERRIDE OTHER AGENCY'S
INDEPENDENT CLASSIFICATIONS
OR TERMINATIONS.
AND THE GOAL OF ALL OF THIS
HERE SEEMS PRETTY CLEAR.
IT'S BASICALLY TO GIVE SEAN
HANNITY MATERIAL FOR HIS
TELEVISION SHOW.
SO THE PLAN AS IT APPEARS
NOW IS ESSENTIALLY KIND OF
PURGE OF THE IDEOLOGICALLY
SUSPECT MEMBERS OF THE
INTELLIGENCE APPARATUS.
>> Tucker: UM-HUH.
IT'S A PURGE LIKE JOSEPH
STALIN UNLESS WE STOP THE
RELEASE OF DISINFORMATION
PEOPLE WILL DIE.
THAT'S WHAT THEY'RE TELLING
YOU.
JUST THE OTHER DAY OF
BALANCED NEWS COVERAGE ON
MSNBC.
KEEP IN MIND AS YOU WATCH
AND REWATCH THAT CLIP THAT
CHRIS HAYES IS NOT A FLACK
FOR THE CIA.
IS HE MAYBE THE NATIONAL
PRESS CORPS BUT HE ISN'T
ARGUING FOR OPENNESS, JUST
THE OPPOSITE.
HAYES IS ARGUING USING HIS
POSITION AS A PUBLIC
ADVOCATE TO ARGUE AGAINST
GIVING THE PUBLIC MORE
INFORMATION.
THESE ARE NOT MILITARY
SECRETS OR THE NAMES OF U.S.
AGENTS WORKING UNDERCOVER
OVERSEAS.
THE INFORMATION IN QUESTION
IS ABOUT HOW THE FBI SPIED
ON AMERICANS WHILE
INVESTIGATING CRIMES THAT WE
NOW KNOW DID NOT OCCUR.
SO WHAT COULD POSSIBLY BE
THE JUSTIFICATION FOR
KEEPING ALL OF THAT SECRET,
THE DETAILS SECRET?
RIGHTLY THE ONLY
JUSTIFICATION WOULD BE TO
PROTECT THE INTEL AGENCIES
FROM EMBARRASSMENT.
THAT'S WHAT THEY FEAR AND
THAT'S EXACTLY WHY THE
FORMER DIRECTOR OF THE CIA
JOHN BRENNAN AND SO MANY
OTHERS ARE ANXIOUS TO
PRESERVE THE VALE OF ADVICE.
>>
SECRECY
I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT THAT
THE COUNTERINTELLIGENCE
PROFESSIONALS CONTINUE TO
CARRY OUT THEIR
RESPONSIBILITIES AND RESIST
THESE UNWARRANTED AND VERY,
VERY IRRESPONSIBLE EFFORTS
TO TRY TO UNDERMINE WHAT
THEY'RE DOING.
>> Tucker: OKAY.
SO JOHN BRENNAN THINKS IT'S
RISKY, UNWARRANTED, VERY
IRRESPONSIBLE TO LET
AMERICAN CITIZENS KNOW
WHETHER THEIR LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES ABUSE
THEIR POWER.
THAT KIND OF TRANSPARENCY,
AGAIN, IS IRRESPONSIBLE.
OKAY.
SO WHAT IF WE APPLIED THE
SAME STANDARDS TO JOHN
BRENNAN HIMSELF YOU?
KNOW THAT AFTER LEAVING THE
WHITE HOUSE BRENNAN WAS
ALLOWED TO KEEP HIS SECURITY
CLEARANCE AND THAT CLEARANCE
INCREASED HIS VALUE AS AN
EMPLOYEE ONCE HE ENTERED THE
SECTOR.
ALLOWED HIM ACCESS TO
CLASSIFIED INFORMATION WHICH
HE COULD THEN SELECTIVELY
LEAK TO HIS COLLEAGUES AT
MSNBC.
HOW DOES GIVING CLASSIFIED
INFORMATION TO JOHN BRENNAN
HELP AMERICAN NATIONAL
SECURITY?
WELL, IT DOESN'T.
IT HELPS ONLY JOHN BRENNAN.
KEEP IN MIND THIS IS A MAN
WHO IS ACCUSED HIS POLITICAL
ENEMIES OF TREASON, A DEATH
PENALTY OFFENSE.
>> THIS IS NOTHING SHORT OF
TREASONOUS BECAUSE IT IS THE
BETRAYAL OF THE NATION.
IS HE GIVING AID AND COMFORT
TO THE ENEMY.
>> TREASONOUS IS DEFINED AS
A BETRAYAL OF TRUST AS WELL
AS AIDING AND ABETTING THE
ENEMY.
THAT WAS THE WORD THAT CAME
TO MY MIND.
>> Tucker: THAT WAS FOR THE
CRIME OF HOLDING A PRESS
CONFERENCE WITH VLADIMIR
PUTIN LAST SUMMER IN FINLAND
WHO WAS TALKING ABOUT THE
PRESIDENT.
WHAT YOU JUST SAW IS NOT
STABLE BEHAVIOR.
JOHN BRENNAN IS EXACTLY THE
SORT OF PERSON WHO SHOULD
NOT HAVE A SECURITY
CLEARANCE.
CLOSE TO A YEAR AGO ON THIS
PROGRAM WE MADE THAT POINT.
BRENNAN NO LONGER WORKS FOR
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT IN
ANY CAPACITY.
HE HOLDS NO OFFICIAL POST.
AND, YET, ACCORDING TO TWO
SOURCES WE SPOKE TO
EXCLUSIVELY TODAY, BRENNAN
RETAINS PERHAPS THE MOST
VALUABLE ASSET HE HAD IN
GOVERNMENT, A
GOVERNMENT, TOP SECRET
SECURITY CLEARANCE.
IT IS TERRIFYING TO THINK
THAT JOHN BRENNAN STILL HAS
ACCESS TO ANY OF THAT
INFORMATION.
BRENNAN IS AN OUT OF THE
CLOSET EXTREMIST.
THIS IS NOT A MAN WHO SHOULD
HAVE A SECURITY CLEARANCE.
SO SHORTLY AFTER THAT AIRED,
THE PRESIDENT ANNOUNCED THAT
HE WAS REVOKING JOHN
BRENNAN'S SECURITY
CLEARANCE.
THAT WAS AS WE SAID ALMOST A
YEAR AGO.
IT WAS JULY OF 2018.
WHAT HAPPENED NEXT?
WELL, PRETTY MUCH NOTHING.
APPARENTLY AS OF TONIGHT
JOHN BRENNAN STILL HAS A
SECURITY CLEARANCE,
AMAZINGLY ENOUGH AS HE WORKS
FOR MSNBC.
ACCORDING TO THE "NEW YORK
TIMES" THE PRESIDENT'S ORDER
WAS, QUOTE:  HAMPERED BY
AIDES WHO SLOW ROLLED THE
PRESIDENT AND BY JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT OFFICIALS WHO
FOUGHT MR. TRUMP ON IT.
KEEP IN MIND THAT PAUL RYAN
THEN THE SPEAKER OF THE
HOUSE MOCKED THE IDEA
PUBLICLY WHEN TRUMP SAID HE
WAS GOING TO REVOKE
BRENNAN'S SECURITY
CLEARANCE.
ACCORDING TO THE "NEW YORK
TIMES," THE SAME THING
HAPPENED WITH DOCUMENTS THE
PRESIDENT WANTED
DECLASSIFIED.
THE BUREAUCRACY FOUGHT BACK
AGAINST THE ELECTED
PRESIDENT AND WON.
THIS SEEMS TO BE HAPPENING A
LOT RECENTLY.
ACCORDING TO BOB WOODWARD'S
BOOK ON MULTIPLE OCCASIONS
GARY COHN, THE NATIONAL
ECONOMIC COUNCIL DIRECTOR
PREVENTED THE PRESIDENT FROM
PULLING OUT OF A TRADE DEAL
SIMPLY BY STEALING THE
RELEVANT ORDER OFF HIS DESK
WHEN HE WASN'T LOOKING.
THE PRESIDENT ORDERED TROOPS
OUT OF SYRIA LAST DECEMBER,
YOU REMEMBER THAT BUT THAT
ORDER HAS NOT BEEN LAID
DOWN.
IT'S BEEN DELAYED AND
MITIGATED AGAIN AND AGAIN.
NOW IT LOOKS LIKE TROOPS
WILL STAY IN SYRIA
INDEFINITELY.
IN FACT, WE ARE NOW SENDING
TROOPS TO THE MIDDLE EAST IN
EVEN LARGER NUMBERS DIRECTLY
CONTRAVENING THE PRESIDENT'S
CAMPAIGN PROMISES.
AS WE JUST SOLD YOU THE SAME
MIGHT HAPPEN WITH THE
PRESIDENT'S LATEST CALL FOR
DECLASSIFICATION.
JOHN BRENNAN AND OTHERS IS
CALLING FOR BUREAUCRACY TO
IGNORE THE ORDER.
THINK ABOUT THAT.
LIKE SO MANY ON THE LEFT,
BRENNAN IS DOING PRECISELY
WHAT HE ACCUSES OTHERS OF
DOING.
YOU ARE UNDERMINING
DEMOCRACY THEY SCREAM EVEN
AS THEY WORK TO DO JUST THAT
HOW ARE THEY DOING IT TO
RECAP CIVICS AT ITS MOST
BASIC LEVEL ALL AUTHORITY IN
REPRESENTATIVE DEMOCRACY
FLOWS FROM VOTERS.
THE PRESIDENT AND THE VICE
PRESIDENT ARE THE ONLY
ELECTED OFFICIALS AMONG THE
MILLIONS WHO WORK IN THE
EXECUTIVE BRANCH OF
GOVERNMENT.
IF YOU SUBVERT THEIR
POLICIES, RATIFIED BY
VOTERS, YOU ARE SUBVERTING